joining us on the line is former
secretary of state mike pompeo he was
secretary of state obviously under
president trump secretary of state
thanks so much for joining the show i
appreciate it
you're most welcome ben it's great to be
with you today so let's talk about the
debacle in afghanistan uh let's begin
with the actual withdrawal strategy and
then we'll get to the broader issue of
whether we should have withdrawn from
afghanistan and if so under once what
circumstances so joe biden announced in
april that we would be withdrawing all
of our troops and then he just sort of
precipitously did it uh we we threw all
close air support we drew all civilian
contractors who were helping the afghan
military with their air force at all uh
and then we just were gone and uh and
the results the taliban took over
immediately what would the trump
administration have done differently
given that there was a timeline to get
troops out of afghanistan as well
well then we had a plan it doesn't
appear that this administration had a
plan at all
our plan was to adhere to what the
agreement was when we began to have the
conversation about how we were going to
get this withdrawal god make no mistake
president trump was determined to get
our young men and women home we'll talk
about that
i think that was absolutely the right
thing to do but we did it in a way that
was based on a set of conditions on the
ground and so all along the way from
where we were when we came in with about
15 000 down to about 2500 by the time
our administration ended we had a plan
and a strategy we were watching closely
the conditions on the ground we had an
agreement that we had outlined about the
obligations that the taliban had to live
up to not promised us they would live up
to we didn't trust those butchers those
evil people but the actual things that
they had to do actions on the ground
that we could see and measure and
observe when they complied with it
we continued to honor our part of the
agreement and when they didn't we
crushed them there were multiple times
they violated the agreement agreement on
how they were going to have
conversations about power sharing
obligations they had not to attack
afghan checkpoints all of the things
that we had
asked them to do in order for us to
begin our orderly withdrawal when they
didn't we we attacked we we crushed them
we made them understand that they had to
adhere to those commitments those
conditions or we wouldn't adhere to ours
which was to ultimately get all of our
forces out that was the plan that was
the strategy the president wanted all
the equipment out all the civilians that
and then and only then would we complete
what would have been the final
complication we made under that
agreement so secretary pompeo that seems
to be the key point here that everybody
is missing the biden administration of
course wants to blame the trump
administration for this but
when you make a deal with the taliban
the idea is that it is conditional as
you keep repeating and if the taliban
did not fulfill the conditions the
troops would not have been withdrawn
when you make it unconditional the way
that biden did the taliban just rush in
and take over everything forthwith and
the afghan military you know the the way
that it was handled with the afghan
military was also a disaster considering
that the afghan military has been widely
reported was built in conjunction with
american help and so it was built with
the idea that there would be close
american air support at the very least
we'd have military contractors on the
ground continuing to work there and
ensure the afghan air force could fly
biden withdrew all of that and made the
withdrawal unconditional
you've got it exactly right and by the
way not only unconditional but rush they
began the it appears the administration
began to panic and tried to rush this
thing through i think they could see in
the spring that this was beginning to
come unglued our response when things
began to deteriorate with the taliban
star take actions we did like was to use
american power with the support of the
afghan forces on the ground and go and
push real costs we instead when the
taliban pushed instead of withdrawing we
pushed back that created ben the
deterrence model
right that this is the reason that from
the time we began this and we signed up
in february of 2020 until the time we
left there wasn't a single american
attack nor a single american killed by
the taliban and they didn't make these
enormous advances we we'd gone we took
85 percent of the forces down and had
none of this this administration pulled
the last pin out of the jenga stack and
caused this collapse it didn't have to
be this way ben this is terrible
planning this sits on the desk of
president biden it was his decision to
do that frankly i think he's wanted to
do this exact thing for a decade
and the taliban did this against a
in the context of a weak american leader
they knew they could push this
administration around and now we have 10
or 15 000 americans stuck on the ground
in kabul because of this weak leadership
so let's talk about the people who are
stuck on the ground in kabul at this
point it seems pretty obvious to me that
we now have the secretary of defense
saying we don't have the capability to
go get those people uh we have the the
general uh the the joint chiefs of staff
general mark milley had
he is saying uh that we
number one this is unexpected number two
we really don't have the capacity to get
those people we're gonna have to rely on
the mercy of the taliban it seems to me
pretty apparent at this point that the
only way the biden administration gets
out of this is just to bribe the taliban
just send them presumably the sort of
money in pallets of cash that we did to
iran when obama was president except now
we will be the chief funders of the
worst regime on planet earth that we
just effectively surrendered to after 20
years of fighting
you know ben not to make light of this
but you know president biden has talked
since he was inaugurated that he wanted
to bring america back that america would
be back
this is back this is back to barack
obama's eight years apologize beg pay
bribe
not not exercise american leadership and
power so i think your point's well taken
they i i don't know how you can have a
senior american military leader say that
we don't have the capability to go get
these folks there's still the capacity
to impose real costs on the taliban if
this administration was prepared to do
that
and force the taliban to allow us to get
these americans back to where we need
them get them not just from kabul but
from surrounding areas as well and get
them to safety this event i can tell you
this feels very much like i was i was a
young person but in 1979 when we had
americans trapped in tehran this idea of
america's fecklessness this feels very
much the same to me today
so secretary pompeo now let's talk about
the sort of geostrategic implications of
all this so uh i will admit freely that
i was an opponent of negotiations with
the taliban i don't think they're
trustworthy i mean you mentioned that
you don't think they're trustworthy
either um and that you're gonna hold
them to to account uh the full
withdrawal from afghanistan seemed to me
always to be an overblown issue
considering the fact that we were
effectively holding a stalemate with
2500 troops zero in in actual combat
capacity as you mentioned we'd had zero
combat casualties from us military since
february of 2020 the afghan military was
absorbing the brunt of the assaults by
the taliban they'd experienced 55 000
deaths since 2014 while the united
states was down to literally zero in the
last 18 months what was the deep and
abiding necessity to get out all
together
well remember we were prepared to do
that only if we got the conditions right
you can go go read the agreement that we
uh signed up for the conditions had to
be met before we were going to take that
final step
we we had a plan too for the second
mission that president trump had given
me and my team which was to make sure
that we continued to keep the risk from
afghanistan as low as we possibly could
that there could ever be an attack from
that place as well we had a
we had a capability that we believed
could deliver that and so we were
prepared to continue to do that provide
american resources to protect and keep
america secure
we we also knew ben and i you you talked
about the negotiations there were many
conservatives who thought it was a bad
idea in the end
you make peace with your adversaries you
don't do it because you trust them you
don't do it because you love them i
hated them there were people in that
room that i knew had killed my friends
man but in the end
you that conversation to try and deliver
a afghan
outcome where the afghans could hold
this on their own where they could find
a reconciliation mechanism as much as
they all have their tribes and their
animosities was a worthy undertaking we
didn't make a whole lot of progress that
was we that was to be expected i was
under no illusion that we'd put all the
afghans in a room by the way we had
afghan women in that room in those
conversations it was known under no
illusion that we would put those afghans
in a room and we would solve this in a
week or a month or even a year this was
going to be a long conversation but we
felt it was worthy to begin it and with
respect to how we handled the american
presence there we always had conditions
that mattered to make sure that we kept
america secure we got our folks out on a
timeline and based on conditions that
made sense for the united states so
secretary pompeo the geostrategic
implications of this sort of collapse
are deep and abiding it is pretty
obvious at this point that china is
rushing to fill the gap china is already
threatening taiwan it would be a shock
if in the near future russia does not
start threatening latvia estonia trying
to break nato all together considering
this is the worst loss uh in nato's
history by a a long stretch uh it would
be a shock if iran doesn't ramp up its
activity they're already ramping up
their nuclear activity what is the
geostrategic outcome of this abject
pathetic uh situation in afghanistan
right now
in some ways this this utterly
embarrassing
outcome in afghanistan is a symptom it's
a symptom of a foreign policy of the
biden administration which is a
follow-on to the eight years of barack
obama which is to supplicate american
interest to those
around the world right as an
understanding of america that is deeply
inconsistent what we have historically
known needed to happen american
leadership designed to put america first
and so your points well taken our
adversaries around the world will now
believe boy if you just push a little
bit if you just
if you just drive america from a
particular place that the response will
be weak it will be one that
underestimates what it is america could
really do and our our adversaries will
see this as an opportunity our friends
will see treachery and this does not
bode well i fear that this will not be
the last time during the reign of
president biden that we see this kind of
american failure and this doesn't bode
well for america's security and if
you're the people of taiwan or europe in
ukraine if you're in ukraine where
they've already given the russians a
pipeline that can strangle that country
the outlook is not good for american
security yeah i think that it's also
true that if you are a an american ally
at this point you have to start looking
to triangulate given the fact that
america is proving itself to be a rather
feckless ally whether it's the people of
hong kong the people of cuba the people
of iran the people of taiwan or now most
importantly the people of afghanistan
being an american ally sometimes looks
like it's more dangerous than being an
american enemy at this point under the
biden administration
well ben i i regret to say that i can
see how they would think that i would
urge them i would urge our friends and
allies around the world america has
always
in the end gotten this thing right i'm
confident that conservative leaders in
congress uh people all across america
are going to demand that america begin
to re-exert its capacity to be a good
friend and partner around the world i
pray that that's the case i hope that
president biden has learned a lesson
from this and we'll see how important is
american credibility is at stake here
and i want this to i want this to go
well for the united states of america
uh secretary of state mike pompeo thanks
so much for your time uh what is one of
the darkest periods in american foreign
policy history thanks so much sir
great thank you ben yes sir
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe